hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
feature to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is the difference between ellipses
and hyperbolas now you're probably
learning about this in your class and
you're maybe having a little bit of
challenge just kind of understanding the
similarities and the differences because
the equations look a lot alike and so
what we're going to be talking about is
how to tell the difference and what all
the ABCs and different components of the
two type of conic sections what they
represent and how to work with them so
let's dive right into this ellipse is
what you'll notice is that you're adding
okay with hyperbolas you'll notice that
you're subtracting both of the equations
they equal one and they both have these
denominators of a squared and B squared
okay so let's look at an ellipse okay
and we'll just kind of look at the
anatomy of an ellipse okay
these ones that I've drawn here are
centered about the origin okay so that
means the center is right at the origin
so if I draw an ellipse like this okay
here's the center the distance from the
center to the vertices okay I'll just
write vertex here that distance is
called a now it's possible that the
ellipse could be longer in the Y
direction okay in the vertical direction
and in that case this is going to be a
okay and this distance to the minor
vertices of the co vertices that
distance is called be sorry you're with
me so far I'll give you some examples of
the equation so say for example this one
could be x squared plus y squared equals
one and this was going to be maybe let's
say 25 and let's just say 16 so what
that means is that I'm going five to the
right and five to the left so number
underneath the X tells you you're going
in the x direction so it's easy to
remember right where as the number
underneath the Y that tells you you're
going to be going in the Y Direction
plus or minus 4 this one here might look
something like this x squared plus y
squared equals one
but the y-squared much let's say maybe
is a hundred or as x squared maybe is
only nine so this tells you you're going
up ten and down ten in the y-direction
and you're only going three left to
right in the x-direction
so in this case the larger number is the
a squared and the smaller number is the
B squared so this is the larger one this
is going to be the a squared this is the
smaller one this is the B squared are
you with me so far so that's the idea so
the distance from the center to the
vertex center to the vertex that
distances a center to the co vertex or
minor vertex that distance is called B
okay now the other component are the
foci and the foci that distance is the
distance from the center to the focal
points and the focal points are going to
be on the major axis that's the longer
axis that distance is C and for ellipses
we use the formula C squared equals a
squared minus B squared
kind of like Pythagorean theorem but
you're subtracting so for this one it's
going to be C squared equals 25 minus 16
which equals 9 and if we take the square
root of both sides we get plus or minus
3 so you want to make sure that the
full-sized F okay are on the longer axis
so we're going to be going right 3 and
left 3 and that's how we find the full
side for this one since it's orientated
vertically because the number underneath
the Y squared is larger than number
underneath the x squared this is our
major axis this is our minor axis our
folks are going to long hum sorry lie
along this axis like this and again what
we would do is we would do C squared
equals a squared minus B squared this
comes up to 91 and if we take the square
root we get plus or minus the square
root of 91 so that's going to be there
actually would be a little bit higher
like this okay a little bit lower so
those are the full side okay now we're
going to switch gears to talk about
hyperbolas now hyperbolas whichever one
comes first that's the positive term
that tells us which direction the purple
is going to open if it's x squared that
comes first it's going to be opening in
the X Direction like the x axis goes
horizontal it's going to open
horizontally if the Y squared is first
it's going to be opening in the
direction that the y axis is that's
vertically up and down so let's look at
any
example let's take this first one over
here say we wanted to graph a hyperbola
that looks like this and like this so
what we have is x squared minus y
squared equals 1 okay just like ellipses
they equal 1 but this one and we're
gonna say maybe is 4 and 1 okay so what
the a squared is for this problem is
going to be 4 so that means that a
equals plus or minus 2 so we're gonna be
going right to the left to that distance
is our a value that's the distance from
the center to the vertices now if we
want to so this will be the B squared
here and if we want to find the distance
to the full side the full set are going
to be along that major axis okay the
same axis that the vertices are on we're
going to use the formulas C squared
equals a squared plus B squared just
like Pythagorean theorem and that's
going to be 4 plus 1 C squared equals 5
C equals plus or minus the square root
of 5 which is about maybe right about
over here and over here ok so just a
little bit further out from the center
now some students will kind of make
these little notes to themselves will
say hmm
so with ellipses the full-si are closer
to the center there on the inside with
hyperbolas the full center further out
from the center they're going to be on
the outside okay and the other way that
students oftentimes remember these
formulas is that and hyperbolas you're
subtracting but in your focus formula
you're adding it's the opposite with
ellipses you're adding here but in your
focus formula you're subtracting so I'm
just trying to give you some hints or
ways of remembering these different
formulas let's look at one more example
with hyperbolas and that's all let's see
if we can fit it in right here if it's
opening like this up and down that means
that it's a y squared variety so I'll
write it down here Y squared minus x
squared equals 1 and here we it doesn't
matter which one is larger like ellipses
the denominator see whichever one's
larger and the ellipses determines which
direction it's going to be longer in
here it's the positive one the first one
that determines whether it's opening up
or down like this one the Y squared is
positive so opening up and down so let's
just say that this is maybe 4 again and
we'll just say maybe this is let's just
say it's 1 so we kind of reversed it so
this is going to be 2
and to so we're going the square root of
four which is two in the vertical
direction in the Y direction to get to
the vertices so I know this was kind of
a quick whirlwind tour of how to work
with ellipses and hyperbolas I'll have
some links to some other videos I did on
ellipses and hyperbolas to dive into it
a little bit deeper with you but I
wanted to just to show you if you're
already understand it a little bit how
did you know tell the difference between
the two conic sections and how to work
with them so I hope this video helped
you subscribe to the channel check out
some of my past videos and I look
forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon